A slow-motion ballet of shattering
spaceships, an army of arachnid
warriors — and the surprising effect that
wasn't CGI at all. Here's what "Starship
Troopers" looks like when you strip away the
special effects. Would you like to know more?
Some of the biggest, most thrilling scenes
in "Starship Troopers" saw the human heroes
taking down the bugs. And one of the biggest
is a moment during a pitched battle between
the two forces that sees the Mobile Infantry
under attack by a gigantic Tanker Bug. It's a
massive insect the size of an 18-wheeler, and it
seems nearly unstoppable. To finally put it down,
Johnny Rico jumps off a ledge
and onto its back. Once there,
he blasts a small hole in its armor and tosses
in a grenade that blows it to smithereens.
To film this dramatic sequence required a mix
of VFX both practical and computer-generated,
as well as some intense on-set stunt work. The
latter was achieved by having actor Casper Van
Dien jump from a real rock face, landing on a
green foam mat below. Later, with the use of
a CGI stand-in and close-up inserts of Rico, the
entire sequence was assembled to make it look like
the gung-ho former high school sports star was
using his fancy football moves to deadly effect.
Other portions of the scene required different
kinds of special effects. A practical,
full-scale version of the Tanker Bug's
back was created for Johnny to stand on.
The rig sat atop a large apparatus capable of
moving the oversized bug prop back and forth.
The shell was also recreated digitally later,
and the two shots were seamlessly joined to
make it appear as though Rico was riding atop
a giant Tanker Bug, fighting for his life.
The final part of Johnny Rico's takedown
of the Tanker Bug sees him being thrown
from its back and hiding behind
the corpse of another Arachnid.
When the dust of the explosion settles,
he stands up proudly in a hero moment,
looking back at his troops — and the
audience — as the bug burns behind him.
Creating just this one simple shot was nearly
as complicated as the entire sequence. First,
a background plate was shot of actor Casper
Van Dien, standing in front of a practical
prop of a warrior bug carcass,
complete with background extras.
Then, the burning Tanker Bug was created
in CGI and composited behind him.
Many of the big action set pieces in "Starship
Troopers" come on the Arachnid planet of
Klendathu. The invasion of the planet winds up
being a botched mission and a total disaster
for the Terran Federation. Filming Klendathu
meant more than just a lot of blue screen,
green screen, and CGI — it also required a
full-scale set of a makeshift military outpost.
Behind the scenes videos from the making
of the film show the set while it was still
under construction. Interestingly, a lot
of the seemingly futuristic elements of the
compound were actually made up of prefabricated
buildings from a company called Sprung Structures,
which offers high-performance, modular fabric
buildings, complete with furnishable interiors.
These allow various industries to set
up working spaces anywhere in the world
quickly and efficiently, and have been
used by companies like Tesla and FedEx,
as well as for soundstages for TV
shows "Big Love" and "The Chosen."
Aside from the army of CGI bugs, in fact,
the entire set is practical — from the
buildings to the desert surroundings. A
behind-the-scenes video from Amalgamated
Dynamics also shows that the carcasses of
the bugs — and people — strewn about the place
were meticulously sculpted and placed on the set.
In a sci-fi movie as ambitious as
"Starship Troopers," you'd probably
assume that most of the alien critters would be
computer-generated creations. And…you wouldn't
be wrong. A lot of them are. Vast armies of
CG Arachnids were created digitally to fill
the scenes of attacking bugs. But the main
warrior bugs also had a working, motorized,
full-size robotic puppet counterpart
for certain scenes, including an
early sequence that shows a bug lifting a
human soldier with its massive mandibles.
The animatronic was designed and built by
VFX icon Phil Tippett, who had previously
worked on "Jurassic Park," while a company
called Amalgamated Dynamics did the actual
construction. And as Tippett told Cartoon Brew,
their usage had a very specific purpose, saying:
"Most of that centered around contact,
like when you actually see a real person
about to be chopped in half and the
beak of a bug. […] You want to keep
the computer graphics people off-screen as much
as possible, because they don't look so good."
Having an actual, moving model certainly adds
a sense of realism to the warrior bug scenes..
What you don't see in the film, of course, are the
robot's many operators who control its movement.
"And, action."
"Up, up."
Casper Van Dien isn't the only actor in
"Starship Troopers" to get to play with
some big CG bugs. His co-star Neil Patrick
Harris — who played military intelligence
officer and psychic Carl Jenkins — also
got in on the fun. The mix of human and
CGI happens at the end of the movie
when Jenkins arrives in the aftermath
of a major human victory. In a satirical
twist ending, Jenkins probes the mind of
the so-called "Brain Bug" and declares that
it's afraid while throngs of soldiers cheer.
Although a life-size model of the Brain Bug
was used in earlier scenes, this one used a
CGI creation, at least for the wide shots.
Seen in some behind-the-scenes footage,
the bug was portrayed on the set by a big
green stand-in partially covered in black
fabric. This temporary, jury-rigged version
would be later removed in post-production
and replaced with a CGI bug whose head
pulsates and whose body oozes slime.
As its title implies, "Starship Troopers" is
about more than just soldiers — it also has a
good number of starships. While there was plenty
of CGI employed to bring some of them to life,
many of the outer space sequences involving
ships — like Carmen's cruiser called the Rodger
Young — were filmed using custom-built
models. One sequence involving dozens
of starships under attack used models created
by artisans at Sony's model shop Thunderstick,
with George Lucas' Industrial Light & Magic, and
a VFX studio called Boss also lending a hand.
Augmented with the use of some CG attack ships,
13 scale starships were created for the scene,
and took a total of 14 months to assemble from
start to finish. The scene, which sees chaos erupt
when the fleet meet an unexpected attack from the
bugs, required the VFX team to put together all
of those ships, plus background elements. The CGI
added later required an advanced computer software
program, though even that could barely handle
the task of compositing so many moving parts.
Behind the scenes, the large models of the
starships were dangled in front of a black
backdrop to capture just one of the more
than 200 individual elements. The large,
empty warehouse space stands in
stark contrast to the final scene:
a frame buzzing with starships,
explosions, and debris.
During the incredible outer space action
scenes, a full-size set was built of the
interior of the Rodger Young's cockpit. But for
their forward view into space, which showed the
horrific destruction of the Terran fleet, special
digital effects were used, rather than any kind
of rear projection or on-set photography.
Instead, it was a standard green screen.
It wasn't just the ships out the
window that were CGI — the window
itself was purely digital, as explained
by Sony Imageworks' Scott E. Anderson.
"The flickering light on the windshield
is actually put in in digital."
That allowed the animators to
add in subtle reflections of the
chaos happening outside the ship,
just like you'd see on real glass.
For director Paul Verhoeven, getting the
moving lights just right was like an orchestra,
and crucial to making the scene
convincing. Colored lamps were
moved slowly from side to side to cast
the right lighting on the physical set,
and were replaced later by scenes of massive
burning ships and explosive collisions.
Amid the space battle above the bug planets,
it's not just the Rodger Young that's taking
fire. Multiple massive starships are struck,
splitting open and jettisoning crew
into open space. Fiery debris from the
entire fleet rains down as shuttles escape their
motherships and try to stay alive in the frenzy.
At least one of those wrecked vessels was
created with elaborate model work.
It'sjust one of many such ships built for
the scene, and it's only when you see
the whole model that you understand just
how large the thing really is. Ultimately,
the ship measured in at a whopping
18 feet and was built with removable
sections to make the destruction scenes
easier to shoot in stop motion later.
"We also had two stop motion animators
who literally frame by frame,
as the ship pulled apart, bent
the middle pieces of the decks."
It's mind boggling how much work went
into each model, with astonishing levels
of detail to convince audiences that this was
a massive starship cut in two by the enemy.
The Rodger Young isn't the only
starship piloted by Carmen. After
that ship is destroyed she also gets
behind the controls of an escape shuttle,
a sequence which required a
couple different moments of CGI.
When Carmen and Zander reach the shuttle
bay, the pod they actually get into is real,
while the rest of the pods
were added in post production.
"We only had the first part of the
set, and the second part of the set,
further away in the background, was added later."
As with the larger starship, a green screen is
also used to make room for computer-generated
images of outer space beyond the windows of
the shuttle. Footage from filming the scene
shows actress Denise Richards sitting
in the cockpit with her headgear on,
and a green screen out the
window of the small vessel.
As described by Paul Verhoeven, the
crash and destruction of the Rodger
Young was crafted in CGI and placed
in the background of this very shot.
"The foreground was shot on a gimble,
because that's where you get all the
trembling and the strange, uh,
the positions of this thing."
These active movements help
give the scene a rocky,
unsteady look as Carmen pilots the
shuttle away from the destruction.
There are some tense moments in the finale
of "Starship Troopers," and one of the most
nail-biting is when Carmen is captured by the
bugs. Finding herself trapped underground,
where she's due to become food for them,
she fails to save her new love, Zander,
who has his head stabbed and emptied
out by the Brain Bug. She is, however,
able to save herself. But if you were on
the set of the film the day that scene
was shot you would have seen something very
different than what ended up on the screen.
Showing up in more behind-the-scenes footage
is the moment where Carmen faces off against
one of the bugs. But for the close-up
shots of her face, she was actually
staring down director Paul Verhoeven while
he shouted and held a broom over his head.
"Da da da da da ah!"
For shots involving the full
bug, he'd be substituted for
the full-size puppet of the Brain Bug,
or a CGI model, depending on the shot.
Meanwhile, Zander's death was pretty much
filmed as it ultimately appeared onscreen.
Production built several models of
actor Patrick Muldoon's head to sub
in for progressively horrifying shots
as the Brain Bug sucked out his brains.
All of this was done in a sprawling indoor set
of subterranean insect caves
that was built for the film.
All these practical onscreen elements just
prove how much work went into bringing
Starship Troopers to life, and are part
of the reason the film holds up so well
after all these years. Using CGI with a light
touch to augment the practical effects rather
than always replace them outright means
that every piece of the action feels all
the more real to the audience. Yeah,
even a giant oozing brain-shaped bug.
"And then strike. Ooh!"